yacht au monde cette position se trouve
sur calme times un jeu aussi qui nous
vient de game show au talent aussi que
j'utilise pour trouver à peu près tous
les jeux indés sur lesquels je fais des
vidéos bref c'est perturbant les stocks
de ce que je dis comme toujours je vis
dans un petit cottage isolé de la ville
a fit alors je voudrais résumer bon pour
vous faire un résumé ça va être plutôt
dur en gros il décrivait que voilà il
est dans une maison à isoler de la ville
qu'il aime le son du vent et d'un côté
un petit peu comme il faut sa vie fixer
le cadre
voilà le cas de ses coûts et dans une
maison bonjour serait une feuille de
papier ou un être humain c'est lui ça va
salut toi les invités devraient arriver
bientôt
n'est ce pas bah j'espère un comme ça
ferait une grosse fête tous ensemble
ok ce qu'on veut pas se poser devant la
télé absolument pas salut j'aime pas cet
endroit est c'est chez moi donc tu vas
te détendre tout de suite hein sinon je
te regarde dans le mur au bon temps à
voile handi dans la cuisine coucou ok
moi qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
kung zhu pets ce music night of the
title please il tape the bride ce week
end service du passé le couteau qui est
sur la table qui a pas de couteaux ici à
à eau
je vais te couper les cheveux tiens ton
couteau pro le bâti un problème tu le
prends je te coupe les cheveux ça suffit
maintenant les pros le [ __ ] comment je
le pose sur la table
ok je peux pas sortir accusé une battue
va le prendre je te coupe les cheveux à
attention je vais te couper les
attentions je te coupe les cheveux
non ça va pas marcher très bien où ça
lui watch hrw
attends je viens de tuer ma femme c'est
une blague ou quoi
je pouvais pas pesé sur la table tu veux
tu que je fasse tu l'as tuée
non c'est pas vrai je le juge lui doit
et le couteau et je me trompe et de 200
je vais donner la lame et des mois il
l'a tué il a tué avec un couteau
non ok pascal meyer presque à me wade
excusez moi c'est faux je veux juste
passer le couteau d'un problème toi
c'est faux je voulais pas la tuer à need
to god and the bad man to cut the power
salut psychopathe ça se passe bien dans
sa tête prend-il je tue des gens qui
savent alors watts un phoque bauges et
au couteau
on arrête là c'est bon je te fais
revivre tout de suite j'en ai marre j'en
peux plus
tu m'entends à oui c'est éric faille que
je coupe le courant à la base
comment on fait e on attend laisse moi
tranquille à temps mais tu es là mais tu
es aussi là mais attendent en fait ce
mec est carrément un psychopathe
puisqu'elle est prisonnière dans son
sous sol
il ya un grand problème et s'il salue
one off aller suis moi c'est par là bas
à n'importe quoi vous qu'est ce qu'on va
faire la photo vous troquez on y va
dégage et tu es un bâtard c'est faux je
suis pas un bastia fois pour payer mes
bruit est d'acord route et que je passe
une partie un bruit de piano c'est ça le
délire allez on y va
ouais haha j'adore c'est génial mais
qu'il faut aller par ou pas je pense
dans cette pièce je le sens bien
nous allons regarder dehors très bien on
va aller par la bombe allons nous en
aller aux cendres à une sorte de
toboggan ou faire du toboggan
bon bah je m'en vais oui carrément s'en
aller par là bas allons nous en un peu
pas très bien à voilà quelqu'un tuer un
humain une feuille de papier attention
j'ai un couteau attention j'ai un
couteau je suis prêt à l'utiliser un tu
ferais attention quand même je dois
appeler la police nom revient la [ __ ]
les mecs qui courent car allant vite
quoi il est parti où ils partent il faut
qu on le rattrape
ok il est passé a trait à la et est-ce
que je peux moins ici trabzon d'accord
donc ça c'est une injustice profonde un
an mais elle aime le foot mais mal quoi
je ne veux pas venir vers toi voilà je
vais aller tout seul dans cette voie à
chaque fois j'ai le réflexe en moi
j'écoute quand il faut l'espace d'un
matin et on s'en bat les couilles de
cette histoire faisons d'abord soir
qu'est ce que c'est que ça bon on a un
nom what we s'est fait transpercer la
tête par une harpe et demi l ennemi mais
[ __ ] mais arrête mec à il est monté il
est monté on va monter et l'ena où es-tu
salue ses toiles et n'en a pas du tout
semblait parfait est-ce que c'est toi et
moi j'aime bien ok vous faut aller je ne
comprends pas stay away et si j'ai pas
envie 1h tutoie rejeta la paire acide
toi sur le canapé je t'avais dit tu
t'assois pas de quoi être bret
attendez elle voler dans le ciel j'ai
mis un coup de couteau de loin et ça l'a
fait disparaître
est ce qu'on est d'accord pour dire
qu'un problème dans cette maison ait eu
tort mon dieu tu vas mourir gala vient
pas que je pensais pas que j'allais vous
tuer à attendez attendez juste amer je
me suis loupé j'ai fait dans le dab à
vous pour sauver les fesses et padre
[ __ ] reviens je sais où tu es pas du
tout bon ça va toi tu es bien mort 1 tu
veut peut-être dû pas quelque chose non
bon très bien excuse moi est ce que tu
sens mais arrête attendait mais je les
côtés pourtant mais qu'à toi toi je t'ai
trouvé tout ce qu'on respecte de toi on
est carrément en train de tuer toute là
toute la planète quoi allez-y ticket
numéro douze suivants
c'est le jeu qui t'apprend à tuer des
gens ce qu'on peut tuer des étoiles non
je pensais que je suis un peu déçu
puisque est pas quelqu un ce placard
dans cette télé sous le lit je veux même
tuer se serrent les mains en l'air très
bien je parle tout seul c'est pas grave
aya le bon canal de jean michel et
l'aide
j'ai trouvé là elle coûte bien trop vite
quoi vient là vient la boucle est
bouclée
je vais te trouble attention faut
quelques bons moments mais qui m'a book
bouclettes excusez moi ce que j'en ai vu
beaucoup
est ce que vous vous appelez la note
c'est la scène la plus riche avec
attention on est pressé regarde regarde
c'est bon d'être remontés pour gros des
sommes pour remonter puis faire quatre
fois leur tour sur soi elle fut classée
les mains des chemins qui est apparu
waouh écoute j'ai tué tout le monde donc
je propose qu'on devient habituel mon
écoute je te laisse pas trop attention
on va le chopper excusez moi je cherche
mon fils si tu as toute ma famille et
moi voulons regarder comme ça vous avez
un problème vous les pourpres et
contient louis on va l'appeler louie
louie
oui tu ne t'en fais pas je préférais un
beau doublé pour toi louis loups les
loups et je suis sûr qu'il est
dérangeant fin de la baule en sortent et
sa famille qui meurt le mec qui
s'emballe estate va jouer du piano
il ya une touchante du bloc tu vois pas
du tout bloc l'a1
ce risque est imputable pour te guider
tout permis aux hommes aux [ __ ] y en
a deux au jus projet aaa le staff a
loupé je vous jure je suis je le faisais
même pas mais qu'il a deux rôles en tête
qu'il a des [ __ ] de rôle et en quoi
sur le temps qu'il en skate a laissé la
fête allait aller est maintenant très
bien donc ils viennent de nous remettre
les phrases qu'il y avait au début en
anglais que je vous ai dit que je vous
ferai un petit brief juste après c'est
exactement ce qu'ils viennent de nos
remettre à la fin sur un fond noir à
ceux qui n'en a ajouté la phrase ce au
calme
voilà ce qui résout donc l'équation qui
y baisser sur x au carré plus deux fois
6 j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
on se retrouve très bientôt dans une
nouvelle vidéo il est même mal j'ai
entendu dire qu'un christiane des
marines profitez bien de votre dernier
week-end de vacances avant la reprise
surtout monfils et à bientôt
il est moi je vous y avez tous les gros
google de ma classe qui faisait ça donc
madame vien ya un débile mental à la
porte la veille un débile mental c'est
comme ça moi pour aller ensemble aux
quais aux deux tu veux